I think that whole notion of being tech
savvy has to go away nobody has to be
tech savvy tech has to be people's
having that's how I want to think about
it you're listening to the Microsoft
Research podcast a show that brings you
closer to the cutting edge of technology
research and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger there's
a big gap between memory and storage and
dr. Anna root padam of the systems
research group with Microsoft Research
wants to close it with projects like
Nava mem which explores how systems can
get faster and better by adopting new
memory technologies and Hashcash which
brings with it the promise of storage
for the next billion he just might do it
today dr. Boden discusses the historic
trade-offs between volatile and
non-volatile memory shares how
software-defined batteries are changing
the power supply landscape talks about
how his research is aiming for the
trifecta of speed cost and capacity in
new memory technologies and reminds us
once again how one good high school
physics teacher can inspire the next
generation of scientific discovery that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
Anna rude padam welcome to our podcast
let's start with a general 10,000 foot
view of your group at Microsoft Research
what do systems and networking
researchers do when they get up for the
morning and what problems are you trying
to solve so systems and networking
research is about thinking of new
primitives all the way from hardware you
know down into the operating system
maybe even at the application level
trying to help applications achieve what
they want at a high level we have
different components in application
software that want to communicate with
each other trying to get access to the
same set of resources because resources
such as maybe memory but ultimately very
limited so if you want to share these
things across and we want to share these
things across multiple customers
multiple applications multiple virtual
machines we need a mechanism to enable
that and what we are essentially doing
is we are trying to get out of the way
of applications as much as possible
while doing these things so that the
application is thinking yes so I'm the
sole user of this system I get the
performance that is promised by there
are hardware capabilities that's what
I'm getting and the systems research is
essentially about adding new
capabilities in terms of adding new
hardware but at the same time making
sure that each of these entities is
thinking hey I have full control over
this hardware and I'm secure while I'm
running this well I also secure while
I'm sharing these resources with others
so I think maybe an analogy is you have
four siblings each one thinks they're
the favorite so I don't have to know
they're not the favorite I think you
just continue to work yes what's the gap
between memory and storage and what are
we doing about it
so traditionally computer systems have
been using this technology called random
access memory RAM RAM and RAM has been
serving as the main form of memory for
maybe three decades now and it's short
term memory right exactly
and it shot them primarily because for
RAM to remember something
it requires power such that it actually
remembers okay and this is a one this is
one you have to continuously reminder
and the process of reminding it actually
consumes energy and that's the
difference between
traditionally what we call as volatile
memory and non-volatile memory or
storage more traditionally non-volatile
memory has been called a storage so
unfortunately traditionally the main
memory which has been volatile in the
sense that you need to continuously
remind it what it is storing requires
power so if you lose power and there's a
chance that you can actually lose your
data so what application developers
typically do when they want to store
data for the longer term is to just
create a copy or a snapshot of the data
that you have in memory dump it onto a
solid-state disk wait for the
solid-state disk like strict knowledge
saying that hey the solid-state disk
goes and programs a fuse what we call
NAND flash cells they essentially
remember that okay I'm going to remember
that this is a 1 and it would do that
send an acknowledgment back to the
operating system saying that hey I've
actually remembered what you actually do
we do remember and even if you unplug me
from the power I'm going to continue to
remember that and because such devices
which remember data for the longer term
they tend to be slower there's a huge
performance gap between memory and
storage so that's one of the gaps the
performance one switches you know it
takes you longer to store something more
permanently and the other gap is that
the amount of memory volume is how many
GB so gigabytes can I actually fit in a
given volume is significantly different
for these two technologies for DRAM
maybe you know a laptop like this I can
have maybe 16 or 8 gigabytes of DRAM and
DRAM being dynamic Ram yes so on the
other hand if you look at the amount of
SSD storage that you have in these
machines the chips would look awfully
the same size you know most of these
laptops these days use something called
an mr2 SSD and their deed a module that
they also use looks about the same size
m dot 2 m dot 2 SSDs it's a form factor
the m dot 2 form factor SSD and the kind
of DRAM that most of these laptops
trained to use they're about roughly the
same size but their capacities are
dramatically different the SSD would
store hundreds of gigabytes I've even
seen some laptops these days come with a
terabyte of SSD but the same size lead
Ram is actually you know just 32
gigabytes or maybe 64 if you're lucky
and that's another gap between these two
this sort of translates into cost
because it's roughly the same amount of
silicon that goes into these things
for manufacturing these so the cost is
roughly the same or the capacities that
are drastically different so why
wouldn't you just get the one that's got
way bigger capacity to about cost the
same good question so you would want to
essentially do that but it will slow
down all of your processing down to the
SSD in the sense that okay I'm gonna
edit one line of my Word document it's
gonna take you noticeably longer every
time you type a word into a Word
document you're gonna see that spinning
wheel okay is there a third gap between
storage and memory that one in them too
so capacity is one this performance in
there's cost if you look at cost per
gigabyte for those two chips you're
gonna pay roughly the same and that's
really the kicker so you would probably
pay about ten to fifteen dollars per
gigabyte for DM and you'd be paying
maybe you know 30 cents or 20 cents per
gigabyte for NAND flash and this as I
said is family because similar amount of
R&D has gone into you know those process
geometry developments it's just that
technologically speaking there is only
so many of these cells I can fit in a
given area without actually heating it
up too much you talked about an arms
race between networking and storage yes
what do you mean by that
and who's winning yeah so what has gone
on over the last 30 or 40 years is
between the power that your CPU has the
power that your memory and storage have
and how fast your networks are they have
evolved at different rates
back in the 90s or you know late 80s to
where you know maybe seven years ago in
Toulouse making tremendous improvements
in CPU speed using all these cool
techniques like you know more cashing
out of our execution speculation so on
and because of these we were seeing
tremendous amount of increase in CPU
speeds so if we go back to the 90s most
of the research was about how do I hit
my disk less often so there's a lot of
research on caching trying to you know
pack as much of your data in DM as
possible so that you hit your hard drive
as less frequently as possible because
of the speed exactly the moment you
start hitting your hard drive that CPU
is underutilized
I'm not running as fast as I can as we
can
so that way you know if we go back to
the 90s CPU completely dominated what
our storage device was actually capable
of like wising on networks was really
slow people were stuck behind dial ups
so there was a similar line of research
even in networks where they were
spending a lot of time in R&D about how
do I cash as much of the web as possible
that suddenly started changing right
around the time and network
significantly got faster
there was investments in broadband
everywhere and the other side of the
networking animation went on not just in
consumer internet but also in the data
centers so when you actually access a
webpage what happens in the data center
is there's all these servers that are
talking to each other to put together a
webpage for you there's immense amount
of communication that goes on between
the servers of a data center and even
that communication was a significant
amount of bottleneck back then and I
want to say maybe you know the early
part of this century is when significant
amount of R&D investments were made in
intra data center networking and the
results of that today we see that you
know our data centers are capable of
networks that are you know 40 gigabit
per second 40 gig Ethernet as we call it
is commodity now when I say commodity I
mean to say that the cost of these
technologies is low enough that we don't
have to say that oh you know what only
the high-end banks and all these trading
shafts are the only ones who can afford
it everyone can have everyone can have
it
so now networks started getting
significantly faster and storage was you
know still lagging behind so this is
what happened in the data centers people
were talking about you know what instead
of fetching the data from my local hard
drive
I have only if you know 32 gigabytes of
DRAM in my own server but networks are
fast enough that I can access a hundred
different servers each of them have 32
gigabytes of their own data so now I
have scale because networks are getting
faster you could think of remote memory
as somehow in a local memory that's what
is how is this understood
that's when significant improvements
happened in the storage world which was
when NAND flash based SSDs started
maturing out of research and people
started you know doing research in
scaling it up saying ok I have maybe
thousand cells today how do I make them
out of millions and you know a billion
cells
and once they figure out how to do that
they became cheap enough that hey I
suddenly have something that sits
between DRAM and hard drives hard drives
are probably a million to ten million
times slower than Dena and it says these
were 10,000 times slower than Dena that
suddenly meant you know fresh air
finally I don't have to worry so much
about hitting the hard drive maybe I can
put some of my really important
information on an SSD and not worry
about my dear I'm being too small so
this sort of broad SSD back into the
announced race where it could tell the
computer networking folks that hey you
know what we don't have to be paranoid
about you know worrying more storage at
the rate that II know I'm actually
thinking of using my networks to go to
servers so your research interest is
systems support for new memory
technologies this is straight from the
website yes and you say the field is
exciting and rapidly evolving right now
mm-hmm so how have computers and memory
technologies changed recently so that
researchers are thinking in new ways
about how to support the changes so you
start thinking about how do we make
faster storage today practical there
have been a lot of efforts into
identifying new materials and material
science technologies that would help you
bridge some of these three caps that I
said you know maybe a cheaper version of
dear maybe a faster SSD maybe something
that is both you know something that is
as cheap as SSD and as fast as DRAM
so in terms of this research it was
probably you know maybe six or seven
years ago we were seeing material
scientists hit a lot of roadblocks in
terms of scaling these technologies they
would look really good in a lab for some
reasons they weren't able to scale them
an example of this technology was phase
change memory still a lot of researchers
are looking into it
it had scalability problem so it
wouldn't scale beyond a certain size but
it had those properties of you know it
it is storage in the sense that it can
remember things for the longer term it
was not quite as fast as data maybe you
know ten times slower 20 times slower in
some instances and maybe even hundred
times
for rights versus leads so we were
getting there but they weren't you know
increasing in capacity and some
prototypes or as expensive as DRAM if
not more expensive so they were not
practical so we were thinking either
practical ways of getting faster memory
faster storage or larger amounts of
memory were you thinking technically or
in line with physics and chemistry we
were thinking more from systems
approaches thinking you know better
architecture of the existing hardware
components that we have and laying them
out better inside the software that we
have so that it feels more like what you
want rather than thinking more in terms
of fundamental material science
improvements so still using the same
materials that you had but making the
technological use of the materials
better yes ok yes how's that going yeah
so this was five years ago when I
started work at Microsoft Research I was
thinking of this problem of how do we
get faster storage today without waiting
for the material science breakthroughs
right around the same time I started
working with a few colleagues here on
this project of improving battery life
for mobile devices this project was
being led by Dunwich and so he was
leading this group called battery life
improvements for mobile devices it was
fascinating for me so when I started
looking at this field of improving
battery life if I was reading papers
about how researchers were getting 5% or
10% improvement in battery life and that
was considered significant primarily
because batteries lithium ion batteries
they didn't scale as fast as Moore's law
they were scaling it you know a curve
that was determined by improvements in
chemical engineering improvements in
converting raw materials like lithium
and packing them as densely as possible
while you know not catching on fire
exactly and those curves were really
slow I mean they were making
improvements like 10 percent every year
so just by modifying some piece of
hardware or software that you have in a
mobile phone if you can get that
additional 10 percent it's like you've
beaten Moore's law you know you didn't
have to wait for those two years and you
have this competitive advantage on your
competitor saying that hey I have the
same sized battery but I can give you
10% extra battery life you know instead
of eight hours I can give you 10 hours
right so this was the game but
project it had this vision set for its
services so I found quite fascinating is
that they wanted to move from the
paradigm of charging mobile devices once
everyday to once every week so I was
like man that seems very challenging you
know I want to help these guys get there
if I can so it was almost like doing
another PhD in battery technologies
understanding you know mobile energy
issues and aspects after coming here and
that's when I you know gotten really
interested in batteries we had an intern
coming from Berkeley he was doing PhD in
batteries he was probably more my mental
than his mentor in terms of he teaching
me about how batteries work what's the
state of the art in the batteries and so
on that's when we saw that the cost of
lithium-ion batteries has been falling
for the last 25 years significantly what
we realized then was you know back in
the 90s early 90s there was this talk
about using batteries to ensure that
your d-damn that needs to be constantly
reminded that hey this is a one this is
a one we can use batteries to survive
other sorts of power outage from the
grid to continue to help DRAM remember
what was trying to remember so it sort
of you know sort of married ideas from
these two things that I was working on
saying that okay why don't we revisit
that problem now that batteries are
cheap and convert some of the DRAM that
you have in your systems maybe laptops
maybe mobile phones maybe even in the
datacenter to make it into faster
storage in the sense that technically
for all practical purposes the
application is thinking that hey this
portion of DRAM somehow magically
remembers that you know whatever I'm
storing in spite of power failures in
spite of the operating system crashing
that's how we started working on this
idea of battery bag DM and that's a line
of research that we have continued in
terms of using more systems techniques
to shrink the size of the battery that
you require for ensuring the non
volatility of a gigabyte of DRAM so
that's the line of research that we've
been doing ever since the last five
years and where are you with that
because my 19 year old daughter has to
charge her phone like four times not
just once a day a week would be like
what so yeah in that problem we've made
significant amount of R&D in the last
few years especially with this
technology called software-defined
batteries so what software-defined
battery
as we see in the battery world we read
these articles right you know hey this
laboratory from Europe has this battery
the charges in five minutes and then you
know by the time we get to the end of
the article it will be something like
hey you know several years before it
becomes practical right and what they're
essentially trying to say is the battery
that we have today which is the
lithium-ion battery the traditional
lithium-ion battery that we use in our
laptops you can think of it as it is
being good reasonable and all the
metrics you care about but it's not
stellar in any of those metrics so I can
explain that further which is that the
things that we care about in a battery
are how much am I paying for it how much
time does it take to charge how many
years does it last and how long does it
hold a charge correct what's the
capacity how much energy can it actually
hold right so if we were thinking you
know can we put all of these different
kind of batteries that are coming
together somehow combine them using new
software and hardware to essentially get
the benefits of all of these new
batteries instead of having 100%
lithium-ion battery maybe I can have 30%
of this new battery their charges in
five minutes which means that you can
get 30% of your charge in just a few
minutes but the moment these batteries
that you've want to put in the same
device that look very different from
each other existing circuitry doesn't
know how to handle it if you use any
electronic server you know electrical
devices you always see that it's the
same kind of battery that goes in it's
four double A three triple e it's never
like you know hey one double a battery
true triple a batteries in 1d battery
that almost never happens that is true
I've never seen circuits can't handle
that
neither can software because it doesn't
know if it's suddenly getting power from
these batteries it's doesn't have enough
voltage it doesn't know how to you know
pick between these batteries for
different things and that's exactly what
we did in software-defined batteries we
tie the batteries that you have to
specific tasks that you want to achieve
and somehow mask using novel
hardware that these are actually
different batteries are they smart
batteries the batteries themselves are
traditional batteries they're in the
sense that there is no circuitry in them
there but this system is the system is
smart enough to identify that hey the
powers coming from you know this battery
right now
so I know exactly what to do to not
confuse the guy upstream
who is expecting exactly this amount of
power that's what Software Defined bad
races and that's helping us innovate in
terms of you know getting you faster
charging getting you more capacity while
not compromising on what you essentially
think of a mobile device how nice n't is
this thinking I mean is it so we shipped
some of the features of software-defined
battery in Windows rs2 yeah so that the
operating system is itself ready to deal
with multiple heterogeneous kinds of
batteries that you have in your hardware
and the hardware itself
we're helping several different OEMs and
several different chip manufacturers to
adopt our designs that will be right
right so is it kind of in a beta stage I
would say so yes the software is in a
stable state and already the hardware is
evolving you know when I was in sales
I used to say cheap fast good ping -
exactly yes that's kind of exactly what
happens with boundaries in this case
good news you know how much charge do I
want to have fast as how fast you want
to charge cheap is you know I don't want
to spend half of my mobile phone cost on
the battery no but that's great so the
battery technology that I don't think I
would have thought hey they're working
on batteries at Microsoft Research I
would think of it as a you know software
although it is software but you have
limitations with physics and chemistry
and all the things a great point to
bring up in on the software-defined
battery project we had two or three PhDs
Ford PhD in chemistry
two or three of them hold PhDs in
electrical engineering and circuitry and
you know I was in operating systems we
had one person in mobile technologies
run with Chandra we had people in the
entire stack end-to-end and it was made
possible primarily because of expertise
in all these fields that we had to think
end to end in terms of this problem I'm
hearing that over and over and over on
these podcasts that people are not just
software people here this it's every
discipline and they're thinking broadly
about problem solving as opposed to just
hey what's the next technical thing we
can do that's really cool
[Music]
let's talk about another project that
you've been involved in it's called
Hashcash and it received MIT tech
reviews top 10 emerging tech awards
about five years ago yes and it's been
dubbed storage for the next billion
right so this essentially goes back to
the storage problems that we had in the
90s before SSDs sure about just when
SSDs were showing up they were really
expensive they were meant for you know
banks and you know trading houses not
really for commodity computing and the
problem that we had back then was when
we go to places where there isn't
high-speed networking available so
places that lack infrastructure exactly
places that lack infrastructure places
that lack stable power supply for
instance oh yeah so even if you have
internet connection if you don't have
power supply and that it's coming in to
the grid then you know how do you deal
with providing something that is I want
to call continuous access to information
right so this is necessary for both
education sector and other sectors that
are increasingly reliant in the
developing world on technology so the
question that we had back then was how
do we pack as much information as
possible into laptops don't focus more
on enterprise workloads but more on
education workloads more you know heavy
on in terms of you know browsing
workloads and so on so what we wanted to
do was can we somehow solve this problem
of you know intermediate Internet
connectivity or intermediate power
availability and deal with them by
putting as much information as possible
in the netbook itself that students and
teachers and educators have access to so
one of the things that we were looking
at was you know why not just take as
much information as possible dump it
onto a hard drive plug it into a netbook
and you know that's your information
retrieval system now and we realize yes
browsers were good in terms of rendering
content they were very efficient but
they were not fast enough to process all
that information from a hard drive by
the time you retrieve all this content
from the hard drive it's going to be
several tens of seconds and people would
lose focus load lose attention over
several tenths of seconds you
yes how we have changed in our patients
love exactly so we were thinking you
know what we wanted to give better
experience and we tried to understand
why it was taking so much time and one
of the reasons why it would take so much
time was all of this information that
you wanted to retrieve was spread
entirely across the hard drive so one of
the things that we wanted to do was can
we bring content that is similar to each
other
as close as possible this is one of the
research that we had done in Hashcash
and the other main part of the research
was if you have a billion things to
remember trying to essentially put a
finger on one of these things it's going
to be very hard you need to essentially
build an index traditionally indices
they were not a huge condensed to
performance primarily because they were
small enough to fit in your main memory
now the moment you start trying to
remember too many things the index
itself is large enough that you start
going on to the hard drive so the
problem in hashcash was I want to
retrieve this piece of information but
the index that will help me to retrieve
this piece of information is itself on
the hard drive so Hashcash we were
trying to solve this very problem how do
you reduce the size of indexes without
reducing the performance of rendering
these pages so what we did in Hashcash
was instead of trying to precisely
remember how a word maps onto a document
what you actually remember is remember
it approximately instead of remembering
all the hundred bytes of the name we
would only remember maybe just the first
few 10 bytes of the name and essentially
it allowed us to index two to three
orders of magnitude more information for
the same size of DRAM that would fit in
an index in the typical indexes back
then would require maybe 100 gigabytes
of DM to index a terabyte of hard drive
we were doing something in a gigabyte of
data so it was two orders of magnitude
improvement in terms of how much
information you could retrieve and with
this we had a lot of deployments in
Africa and we made a lot of tie ups with
people in the education sector
especially the OLPC One Laptop Per child
and we made it available for people to
use it inside the OLPC project and
that's how you know in God award so it's
been deployed in a couple of areas
to see how it plays and the hope is that
you'll be able to deploy it further in
places and sectors that don't have the
maybe the material resources yes to
invest in these bigger more expensive
systems right right
tell us about Nava mem your memory and
storage cloning project that attempts to
bridge the gap between DRAM and SSD so
that's the project which is about system
support for memory and storage yeah
we've been doing so storage and memory
research in the data center is all about
trying not to lose the data that you're
storing online the photos that you are
storing online in Microsoft Azure or
another cloud services their goal is to
make sure that they never lose your
photographs and the way they do this is
by creating copies of your photograph
and storing in as many servers as
possible so storage systems research is
about creating coffees as fast as you
can so I thought okay I try that just
unpack a little bit more about yeah so
when I was talking about the
functionality gap between memory and
storage issues memory is temporary if
the power is gone you sort of lose the
data that is there yeah they need a
battery or you need some other way of
helping ensure that DM continues to
remember that it's a one it's a one it's
a one solid on the other hand the reason
why you're storing this is because this
is data that you actually care about
right so when you care about something
you want to make as many backups as
possible because what happens if there's
a permanent failure in this hard drive
so what the data centers have done is to
deal with these problems of you know
hard drive failures is you know what I'm
going to put your data in three
different hard drives and hope that not
all three hard drives will go down at
the same time the probability of that
happening is astronomically small it's
not just about creating one coffee but
it's about this promise that you want to
give to the customer that I will never
lose your data regardless of which
technology I'm storing it in so how do I
make storage how do I make this problem
of storing something durably that you
know this promise of not losing
something not be the bottleneck in the
system and especially in the light of
this new technology that we're seeing
which is sort of a non-volatile memory
is what we're calling it it's sort of
bridging these gaps between DRAM and SSD
but at the same time it's not as fast as
DM not as cheap as SSDs
so it's still a hierarchy I still need
to understand all the customers would
really care about speedy I want to put
them indeed a mine battery back Tina who
are the customers were ok with a little
bit of slowdown I want to put them in
this new technology who are the
customers who really don't care about
speed maybe they're just uploading
photographs in the background in their
phone right so maybe I'm gonna put them
on the SSD things like that so you're
really customizing your thinking for the
kinds of people that have different
kinds of needs because you can't do all
three cheap fast good yes yet yes right
yeah you're working on it yes it happens
storage probably would have surprised
Network and you know compute and if it
is not there's still more work for all
of us to do tell me a little bit more
about 3d crosspoint so 3d crosspoint is
this new technology that Intel and
micron have come up with it's kind of a
solid-state material that can actually
remember information for longer periods
of time without being reminded again and
again it still has the problem you have
to remind it maybe once every three
months months every six months that it
is storing a one or a zero once every
three months and six months is lot less
frequent and remaining data which is
probably tens of thousand times a second
you've reminded this is a 1 this is a 1
and so on
so the amount of energy and power it
consumes to actually represent a bit is
significantly lower
what this means is that you can pack
more number of bits in because you know
what continuously pumping power into it
so it can dissipate that energy faster
but at the same time it's still nowhere
close to SSDs in terms of capacity as I
said SSDs can have maybe you know like
two or three or four terabytes but still
two terabyte MDOT - which is about the
size of Snickers bar but not as thick
it's probably as thin as a fruit roll-up
you know so that's how big these SSDs
are these days in servers and laptops
and in that same size you can probably
pack 128 gigabytes of 3d crosspoint and
maybe 32 gigabytes of data so that's
kind of the gap that we have in terms of
how much you can put in a given volume
and the gap is roughly logarithmic in
the sense that if DRAM has a speed X
this guy has X by 10 and this guy has
maybe X by 10,000 so you can think of it
as a spy
from seeing that okay I'm getting
slightly more memory and where it's
still not as fast as Deena but
fortunately it's not as low as SSDs
[Music]
let's talk about you for a minute you're
young and some people around here say
you're one to watch
what's your academic background and how
did you end up doing research and doing
research at Microsoft Research yeah so I
think my interest in science sort of
goes back to this really good physics
teacher that I had in my 11th grade this
was time when I was actually preparing
for what we call the Joint Entrance
Examination in India the Joint Entrance
Examination in India is an examination
that tens of thousands of kids write
every year to get into these top
engineering schools in India called the
Indian Institutes of Technology IIT yeah
so this lecture will hear a really
inspiring way of telling us what was
going on in the physics world that's how
I got interested in science or you know
cutting-edge science and the transition
from physics to computer science
happened primarily because towards the
end of the physics course he would show
us more and more demos of how atoms and
how dynamic systems such as you know
maybe a car moving you know cat chasing
a mouse or even you know like black hole
simulations he would show us in these
really complex computer programs and
animations that's why I got interested
in what he was using to make those
animations he would actually program
these things using Java applets these
were programs that he was writing
himself I got really interested in that
you know you know what is this
programming he was writing them just to
demonstrate to use these concepts yes
fascinating yeah so that's when you know
my love for physics morphed rental of
computer science fascination for
computer science I didn't know what
computer science was you know back then
we didn't have a computer at home my
first computer was when I was in my
sophomore year the first year in IIT I
shared the computer with a lot of other
students inside the shared laboratory
but the first personal computer that I
had in my own dorm room was in my junior
year what year was that that was 2003
Wow and that was you know when you know
I started discovering so many things
about what he did back then using the
programming languages for demonstrating
all these cool things for us in physics
and I realized you know program
so cool and they too kind of came
together exactly and that's how you know
the rest is mystery
yes and after as I said you know in the
third and fourth years when they gave us
choice of choosing what that's right
there's no oh wow now I can finally
figure out what is it that I like in
computer science what is it that I want
to do and something that we did in
operating systems really stuck with me
it was this this thing about systems
research as I said was to make the
system that you're willing as
transparent as possible since that you
want multiple customers and multiple
applications or multiple processes to
use the same hardware and somehow while
doing this you want to vanish you want
to disappear you don't want to get in
their way because yes you're helping
them share but in doing so if you hinder
their experience it's not a good thing
right so there is so many cool new
algorithms about doing this you know
adding value well you know not hindering
their experience it's almost as if the
destiny of systems is to vanish it's
like here's the thing that wants to
destroy itself I have an operating
system but I don't want to get in your
way
very amusing thing there is something
and its whole purpose is to vanish
computing should be something that is
natural it should not be a learning
curve it should be like interacting with
other humans interacting with other
things in the real world just get out of
the way yes there's a lot of technology
behind all of this working just get out
of the way that people interact
naturally with whatever innovation that
you have we have seen that in terms of
natural user interfaces all the
wonderful research you know our
colleagues are doing in a record system
I don't natural user interfaces using
voice for achieving complex tasks using
gestures for achieving complex as people
are used to doing gestures right hey
next photo for instance as simple as
that so kind of Tony Stark in his
downstairs lab and he just waves his
hands and things happen exactly it has
to be more natural so I think that whole
notion of being tech savvy has to go
away nobody has to be tech savvy tech
has to be people savvy that's how I want
to think about it I never eat that um
you are one to watch and thank you
thanks for coming in and talking to us
today thanks for having me here
a pleasure doctor to learn more about
dr. anariba dom and how microsoft
research is working to close the gap
between memory and storage visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]